now that we have everything set up the
way we need open Chrome on your
development machine and go to Chrome
inspect make sure the site you want to
debug is open on your mobile device and
then connect your laptop to your mobile
device via USB then confirm that you
want to allow USB debugging back on our
development machine we can see a list of
the attached devices and the chrome tabs
that are open on the device you can even
open other tabs you can also focus on
specific tabs you can reload them and
you can even close a tab the best part
of course is that you can inspect the
pages that are running on your mobile
device from your development machine
let's take a look one of my favorite new
features is the new screencast mode this
allows you to drive the experience on
your mobile device from your development
machine you can click on links and see
them update simultaneously on the device
as well as on your desktop
as you can see you have all the familiar
features from the development tools
available for mobile now